thanks for joining us at 11 o'clock i'm
denise valdez and i'm brian loftis last
year metro police found 123 victims of
sex trafficking younger than 18 locally
now the victims can be approached
anywhere a mall a park even in their own
neighborhood so that's why tonight the
las vegas summerlin rotary club held a
sex trafficking awareness forum they
really wanted to shed light on a growing
problem here and also to warn parents
what they need to watch out for madison
kimbrough joining us now live with the
details madison
no longer is it just something that
happens here on the strip it's
considered a hidden crime and sex
trafficking nowadays looks a lot
different than before with technology at
the fingertips of so many
somebody is benefiting financially from
the cell of that child's body for sex
las vegas a top destination for sex
trafficking with roughly 5600 child
victims statewide tuesday night's child
sex trafficking forum was meant to
educate and inform the public on what's
going on here locally in places most
wouldn't expect it's happening in our
community it can happen in children's
homes it's happening you know kids are
going to school
it's not always that sort of you know
kidnapping situation the conversation
must start with your child be upfront
with them as to why you're checking
their electronics and monitoring their
behavior at school being the victims
being immature and young
they don't know what they're getting
themselves into then they're in too deep
and it's difficult for them to get out
of it another important tip pay
attention to where and how your child
gets new things sex traffickers will use
gifts to lure your child
and to report any such behavior you can
call or text the hotline number that we
have up on your screen reporting live
madison kimbrough live local now